foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
to me
the businesses that I managed and deal
exclusively in cash
[Music]
the last is that you cannot touch but I
think I see a lot of law Breakers up in
this house
[Music]
I got a little treat for y'all tonight
we're gonna see if he's still got some
magic in that mic
foreign
[Music]
I wish we had known you guys back in our
day
well I'd say it's still your day man
uh
[Applause]
[Music]
on the live show there's a very
arresting dance that really takes your
breath away
it made us want to make a third movie
this is a place where we can redesign
what Magic Mike actually is
[Music]
you cannot say to what we've created so
far isn't special so I'm not going to
just let us give up on it
[Music]
hell yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
only beat his February 10th special
Advanced screenings February 9th rated R
[Music]